here's your starting pitcher shane
mcclanahan going out there making his
11th start of the season you see the
good numbers so far for the young
left-hander 2-2 record the 403 era the
strikeout to walk really good for the
kind of stuff that he features 54
strikeouts to 14 walks uh sitting on
that 97 mile an hour fastball duane
should be a lot of fun to watch today
and here is ohtani getting set to lead
it off and here's the lefty's first
pitch hit on the ground to second lau is
there in the tosser first
and that's a cut to mince out number two
two up two down here's anthony rindone
there's a swing and a missed strike
three and mclanahan fans rendon atlanta
hand just getting a three up three down
innings this is where this man's career
was born alex cobb he's pitching this
ball park a bunch his 60th career start
at the drop he's looking for his first
career win against the raises era pretty
solid three seven six
dives and disappears that's exactly what
he did he did bounce it that's a one two
three pitch strikeout brian knight home
plate umpire one away randy arose arena
10 home runs on the season 11 stolen
bases as well
bouncing ball cobb reaches out and grabs
it both of these pitchers on their game
one two three the lead-off walk for
gosling and up comes max
and a cut stassey miss he's out on
strikes could not catch up to the
fastball up there and then strikeout
number three joshlin forced out and two
outward aboard
blinder into right margo's right there
to make the catch so man left we go to
the bottom of the second scoreless
here's manuel margot
that's a shot back into left ward will
turn around and that baby's gone
line drag over on by manuel margot
his eighth home run of the year
and the range take the two nothing lead
how about margot to get him oxygen
inside corner good fastball that's
strike three margot with the homer the
angels in business runners at first and
third and shohei otani will be the next
batter as that one's rolled to the right
side up and over the head and into right
field
ohtani with positive contact he's
hustling into second with a bounding
double for shohei and the angels get one
back it's two to one at crazy speed of
shohei ohtani
and uh cutting the mess that he got him
to a big strikeout for the first out of
the inning and anthony rindeaux now will
be the next batter
100 miles an hour it's popped up to the
right side that's a fair ball that's
down one run will score another angel
shohei right behind
he will take it he fought off 100 and
his reward his team leads it three to
two my goodness i know those guys with a
good chance they played golf on that off
day when they got down the saint
petersburg area that was a tremendous
flop shot here's stassi he struck out
his first time
thumb sprain and he is out on strikes
here second strike out of the inning so
one out one on and here's jim choi
flying to left field this only time
there goes the rosarita and a liner into
right
the rose arena will go to third they'll
put the stop sign up for him there
first and third on the base hit by
george
so two outs and here's joey wendell
wendell beats it the other way that's
gonna get a rosarian home
joy up to second and the base hit to
left ties this game at three the rbr's
single off the bat and joey wendell
let's see what brett phillips can do
with minute first and second
drive all back into deep center
that ball is going to carry over the
head of the garris
joyous score
wendell will score in the third a triple
from phillips and the rays grabbed the
lead brent phillips triples over the
head of the center fielder and the rays
are up by
this pitch is low gets away here comes
phillips and he will score
boy phillips
very alert got a great break
down that third baseline and when matt
ball squirted away he was gone in an
instant
and the pitch swinging a line drive to
short backhanded nicely by wander franco
and the long throw got him two down that
ball was hit hard and wander had to play
the field there you know you don't play
many fields like this except for when
you're here here's phil gosling right
here
that's the cut miss counseling out on
strikes another one two three inning
back to back for mcclanahan with two out
see if another lefty and lefty match up
can work for the raise here's team on
choi that's a lighter base hit into
center and here comes the rosarito
across the plate joy wasting no time
jump down the first pitch
makes it 7-3 back to the mound goes
mcclanahan
stassi is going to lead it off
and that will be strike three call
spanxy out on strikes for the third time
today in a row retired by mcclanahan fly
ball short right center margot closes to
make the catch and a quick sixth inning
7-3 tampa bay two out nobody on and
leaves it for mike zumino on two and two
swinging a high fly ball way up into the
rings down the left field line it hits
the c ring keeps going and carries out
for a home run
he hit it over the ring and it carried
out of here a home run zanino and it's
eight to three rays i thought it hit the
the b ring actually i thought it hit it
but i think it cleared it it went over
it and now with runners at second and
third nobody out g-man choi will be the
batter
he shoots it up the right side
that ball is going to be off the wall
extra bases one round is scored
meadows
stopped at third he wasn't sure
if rendezvous had a chance to catch it
or not so rosarina scores meadows is in
third on the double by joy the one out
that'll bring it brett phillips
line drive into right there's the base
hit
meadows will score the bases will remain
loaded now the ball loose that's going
to bow down near the
dugout allowing joy to score and the
other two runners to advance margot goes
to third and phillips winds up at second
so phillips lines a base hit head to
right we have reloaded the bases for
wander and that will be ball four he
draws the walk to force home a run randy
rosarina who started this inning with a
walk comes up with the bases loaded here
that's a fair ball backhanded back to
the back long throw not going to be in
time another run scores phillips crosses
the plate and rose arena gets an rbi
last chance for the angels juan lagarus
and the pitch are cut in the mess that's
going to end at the rays win it they get
10 strikeouts on the day and win this
game 13-3